i've got all these taxis i'm doing
really well oh uber oh they're terrible
but then actually three years later
you're like
i've had to liquidate my businesses this
sucks because you've become really good
at finding deals you're buying houses
yourself
but people are now paying you it's
almost like you're getting paid to view
houses
hey what's up welcome back to my channel
this week i want to introduce you to mo
ella he is absolutely storming it in the
property investment world and on this
video he's going to be sharing his
success in property exactly how he's
making a very very good income through
property investment he's just bought a
motorhome he's buying a hmo bio
refurbished refinance he's employed
people to run his deal sourcing company
and now he sat in my living room so mo
welcome to winners on a wednesday hey hi
thanks for having me now we go back a
long time we've been friends for years
you've been in property for years but a
couple of years ago i managed to
persuade you to join the property
investors academy you did but why don't
we start from the beginning talk me
through your backstory and property and
how we met okay
so my backstory i had already owned a
few properties
um and
back in
2016 we were at an event in in london
and we were outside i was having my
usual [ __ ] outside and there was this
energetic guy out there singing this uh
song by loren
and i videoed you actually singing
because you thought i was nuts i thought
you know
love the energy and everything you know
i thought no this guy says something
about this guy
ever since then i started following all
the all your stuff and started coming to
some of your programs and your crash
courses and things like that i think it
was a training kings one yeah
right at the beginning when you started
doing them i i went to that i ended up
buying a book writing course i still
haven't wrote my book yet but that's
coming soon
and
i just thought okay and then
after that you you started launching
your your property uh crash courses so i
send in a couple of them and and
i intended other crash courses as well
and decided uh you know
market research is so important you
you've got to see who you want to train
with and so on so i checked all the
others others out and and we decided um
to train with you
so
2009
um i joined your courses before so it
took you three years
to decide yeah which trainer you wanted
to go with yeah yeah the reason um
reason before that i had my businesses
running i had a takeaway business a taxi
company a very successful one i had
restaurants as well yeah yeah very
successful we were so successful in the
taxi business we won a million pounds
worth of contracts and um
the competitor was was gunning for us
and he's well in there with the councils
the old boys network
and he was quite successful actually he
ended up taking us out
we had two choices either asset strip
and sell or just shut down so
i had to asset strip sell liquidate the
the company
um it was a difficult time for me you
know everything that i'd built over the
10 years i had to dismantle it was that
like uber and stuff that was taking you
out it wasn't uber no it was a local
competitor uber came on the scene i
remember you bitching about uber in
2016. yeah yeah you were uber terrible i
was like they're brilliant yeah you were
like no
they were brilliant for the customers
they were really bad for drivers i was a
driver's man you see yeah with me having
all that experience on the road
um so yeah
uber came along half price taxis and
really really crazy stuff going on in
the industry so with your taxi business
yeah how big was the firm did you have a
lot of members of staff yeah yeah i've
employed hundreds of staff in my time
yeah i had a really good team of staff
that were running the show for me uh we
grew it from scratch from one man in a
taxi to 50 cars yeah you know we were
school contract specialists we did a lot
of wheelchair transport children with
special needs we
took them the training program we were
at was a training program with t
harvecker yes it was and that was back
in 2016. your testifying for this as
well i know me really well now i've
known you for like five years i myself
go on a lot of training programs i
invest a lot of money in training so do
you yeah so you'd gone on some business
training yeah had that helped the
business did you manage to save it or
massively well it helped the business
when i when i went on to harvecker's
training i came back and doubled and
quadrupled the turnovers of the
forecasting and grew the businesses
right i went from one one takeaway to a
taxi company upstairs then another
restaurant then another takeaway yeah so
after doing that training i grew my
businesses so yeah
training always helps you gotta
educate yourself and get yourself out
there and the more you learn the more
you end right yeah
so when did the taxi business really
start taking a hit and when did you have
to liquidate the company 2017-18
is when i had to um i was going through
difficult times and so on yeah i had
problems with the council
and
you know unbelievable the things that
went on it was
crazy stuff um
i i had to asset strip and sell
everything then i had the takeaway
business left
again the restaurant i got rid of that
the other takeaway got rid of that and
my last takeaway and i thought my
daughter was born at the time as well
you see so i thought do i work nights
and evenings and so on and run this or
do i just
uh start again clean slate start again
so i'll take a year out
and i'll study and i'll do the training
join the academy
and
trained myself
in property
joined your courses
started doing all the courses one by one
going through the process taking life
nice and easy learning as we go along
studied everything property everything
to do with property got my head right
into it and studied study studied and
made sure that i was going to make the
right choices
cleared decisions of which way i'm going
to go in property
obviously when when you join your the
academy
i've got a toolbox of of things i can do
yeah um yeah and that really helped but
i made choice i made sure a choice to go
down the deal sourcing side and brrs um
i'll do about that
further down the line i think i'll be
doing some developments and things like
that but
making that choice right deal sourcing
i'm going to concentrate on deal
sourcing the target is to get x amount
of deals out every week build an
investor list and just concentrate on
that and you've done really well on deal
sourcing and you've gone on to i know
you've bought your own investments
you've got a property even right now
which is about ready to complete yeah a
massive which we'll get on to a massive
bar refurbishing finance hmo you've
bought a motorhome which you're renting
out as well which is cool but i'm just
trying to work out so
when you
when you came to to to the property
courses with me like where were you at
like were you in a situation whereby
your business said
uh you've got money from your business
you're looking to invest or you're a
point where your businesses have kind of
been a struggle i know you'd worked
ridiculously hard for the last 25 years
in business where were you at what was
the reason that made you come to
property well
um obviously i had to dismantle my
company so i was taking a year out and i
wanted to just we stressed out study oh
you're stressed depressed um yeah the
the full shoe bang when you when you've
worked so hard to build something and
then you've got to dismantle it it was a
horrible process to go through yeah yeah
and it makes you feel [ __ ] you question
so many things in you know why the hell
am i here why the hell am i doing this
why why do i even bother shall i just
shall i just get a job and just be the
normal nine to five guy yeah that must
have been really tough though because
you'd worked i know you really well and
i know your bit your back story you were
working like 100 hour weeks yeah
building the business yeah hell yeah
yeah you had to put it in
um
that's that's great experience doing
that um you know 25 years of doing that
i was i was i was single i was able to
do it i didn't you know have
responsibility i was able to put it in
my daughter came along my life's changed
i've got responsibility
so i i had to change my mindset the way
i do things i couldn't be out all hours
you know of the night got family to look
after got responsibilities
so i had to um
decide right which way am i going what
am i going to do what am i going to
focus on how close were you to getting a
job
and mercedes benz opened up in softball
i thought oh i like mercs i wonder if i
can do sales sales did you apply uh i
didn't apply no because i thought wait a
minute no that's not enough for me
but you were failing enough but you were
getting to the point where you were
looking for jobs yeah yeah yeah i was
thinking about it i was thinking
but no why did it take you three years
we met 2016. i told you all about my
property business i just launched the i
just registered my property training
company at the time and you were saying
to me i'm interested i'm interested what
took you three years to actually come to
my training well as you can imagine i i
already had businesses on the go and i
had a lot on my plate and um you know
it was some it was a seed that was
planted then and 2019 is when it started
to grow and and i decided right i'll go
further with it
i did have my businesses and they were
doing well so i was already busy right
um so it took you
you you didn't come to me straightaway
because you weren't in a bad enough
place
so you came to me when you're at the
point where you're like i need to start
looking for jobs this is terrible
well uh yeah you could say that so
what's the lesson the lesson is uh just
um just go just always keep yourself
trained in other things is it yeah
because it's interesting isn't it when
we met in 2016 you were like i've got
all these taxis i'm doing really well oh
uber oh they're terrible but then
actually three years later you're like
i've had to liquidate my businesses this
sucks yeah yeah you know so you're a
point now he didn't have loads of money
to invest you didn't have successful
businesses bringing in cash flows you're
in a very different place exactly but
then you've built back up the rise fall
and rise again of muhammad ullah boom
yeah the roller coaster of life is up
and down up and down businesses like
that yeah all the other key business
people are watching him on youtube sure
how they had to covet here and so many
businesses suffered with with covid yeah
and
regrow
the world closed and then the world
opened up again to build that business
back it takes time strength energy you
know a lot um
to do to to bring them back some will
survive it some some won't there'll be a
lot of liquidations and so on going on
yeah and that's the life of business
that's so um
things that you've got to be able to
handle when you're in business
the ups and downs the good times and the
bad times yeah because it's problem
solving you've got absolutely so many
problems so 2019 you decide property is
the way for me what made you take the
plunge to invest a lot of money into
joining the full property investors
academy because you did the crash course
and you did some of the free training
what made you
pay so much well
it's not so much really the the value
that you got for the amount that i paid
10 grand plus that and you go and buy a
franchise it's a hell of a lot more than
yeah um i checked with other companies
other training providers out there there
was a company that was selling a
franchise style of training and then
you'd have to pay them a fee every every
month as well and i thought no that's
not me but the value that you were
giving and the training that you were
given
um was was so much better than
everything else out there out there on
the market
he'd created this platform this absolute
everything was checked off you you
winners on a wednesday the way you do
the courses
i was like looking at this young man
thinking wow he's smashing it i travel
at 100 miles an hour this guy's going a
thousand miles an hour and he's doing
all the right things that uh that that
you need yeah the training was
absolutely amazing so basically you
looked at it from a business perspective
i thought actually you want to get step
into a new industry normally if you want
to if you want to take a new profession
you got to go to university you got to
go to college and for you it was just
like that basically then yeah yeah it
was i mean i didn't like college i
didn't like school um i was hands on get
my hands dirty go out there work hard um
and learn learn as you go yeah and
by taking this property training course
the training that i did previously it
showed me that training training your
brain to gain
is so important to get the training
it took me while we turned 2019 2021 i
did have a couple of years um
uh break during covered and things like
that enjoyed myself and then launched my
company
and
and it
it works it's
ev everything just fitted in nicely yeah
yeah so when you went through the
academy then 12 month training program
you learned about
packaging and selling deals buy
refurbished refinance hmos all the
different types of properties that you
could find
what happened next
a load of notes about that much it piled
up um so i i had to make a choice which
route was going to go down as a
nine to five i call it um business so i
chose the deal sourcing alistair your
trainers
everybody you know i
learned so much of them and decided
right i'll do that i'll focus on doing
deal sourcing
looking after investors there's lots of
busy professionals out there that
haven't got the time we know it takes
about 40 hours
of our time to find a really good deal
and things like that and i thought right
i can do that uh from home i can work
from home be on the road and and source
deals for investors
in the process
i can build my own portfolio up as well
this time with education my previous
properties were just yeah just dropped
the money in there thank you very much
uh no calculation but now it's a whole
new mindset of looking at property and
what works and what what doesn't yeah so
it's very very important to get an
investment property that actually works
and when you're a trained investor it's
a different ball game all together so
you start then finding good deals for
investors yeah from what you've learned
from the academy yeah you then find the
deal and then you pass it on to an
investor that could be someone you've
networked with someone who's also on the
academy that just wants to just pay you
or whatever and then the money you then
keep that and you can then live off that
money or you can put it back into a pot
and reinvest it so those types of deals
now you've become very successful at
doing that to the point where you've
built up a company what's the name of
your company action invest actually
invest you've actually employed people
that are that are running the business
you're packaging and selling on average
how many deals would you say per week or
per month uh one one deal per week at
the moment and how much on average are
you charging the investor for that
service anything from three to five
thousand pounds so three to five
thousand pounds if you think anything
like that every week yeah i mean that's
a very successful business model it is
it is i mean the targets only to to do
two deals a week for for that company
yeah obviously we can i think we'll
overtake that um you know i've employed
a young man adam brown he's absolutely
fantastic he's like my right hand man
and you know we're working together on
his goals as well and his targets and
things like that and we work well
together
um we met on training events and things
like that so it's just like-minded
people being so you give him
a salary plus a small commission yeah he
does the general running of the business
but you then oversee him and you build
the network of investors and make sure
the business happens
so that's a super successful business
now to set up a business like that
although you're making money in property
you actually need that much money to set
up a business like that no that was one
of the beautiful things about it and
you you
uh ten thousand pound plus v8 for the
training okay that's that's fair and to
set the setup cost it was very very low
yeah it was like this is brilliant yeah
it works works absolutely perfect yeah
you know i've i've
they call me the three-year academy
member because they keep going back and
keep networking and keep learning and
keep
you know supporting other people that
are coming in new to the to the academy
and things like that and alice there
goes well you're the three-year academy
member
because the thing is the academy is a
12-month program but the way that we see
it is
we know once you've finished the 12
months it's not like we go right off you
go don't ever see you again and uh that
that you're definitely proof of that
because you've continued to stay in
touch you still come to a lot of the
events um you're part of the furniture
and we've continued to to support you
what you're doing um what advice would
you give to somebody that's saying i
haven't necessarily got loads of money
to invest in property i just want to
make some quick pounds yeah packaging
and selling deals like no did what would
you say well um
in in my business we work with a cold
sources as well right so what we've done
is create a network of code sources up
and down the country so anybody that
jumps on our mailing list um and they're
in london say we still might have a deal
for them in london because we've got a
co-sorcerer in london so anybody who who
has to get the skills of deal sourcing
under your belt once you've got that
skill you can network with me anybody
out there and and sell a deal through
through them right yeah so you don't
even need a company
they don't need a company they just got
to be registered and so on which it's
quite simple if they're looking into
deal sourcing they'll know exactly what
they need to do
and and it's very minimal the cost to to
set up yeah and once you co-source with
somebody
it's a it's a way of right okay we we
analyze the deals that come to us via
the coastal so they make sure it is a
good deal and and we sell the deal on
for them and they get so basically what
they do is so kodi or sourcing gears
where one person
goes out and finds a deal but they've
got no investors
so they then contact someone who's got
investors and say can you sell it for me
or someone who's got lots of investors
that's really well networked but hasn't
got a deal you can find us a deal
sourcing company and you can just code
your source exactly coleslaw sourcing is
the future yeah we work with a lot of
cool sources up and down the country
absolutely brilliant uh you know you've
got to put it in and you'll you'll get
it out talk to me about your
motor home purchase and what made you
decide to buy that uh a fun business i
call it the fun business my idea with
with that was
to
i like the numbers um in in
renting a vehicle i used to have a fleet
of taxis in my company i'm used to
managing uh you know a good few vehicles
and i thought i went on a holiday in in
2017 um 2018 and i i hired one and i
thought this is brilliant weighed it all
up
the the actual motel i thought this is
the perfect one for a rental business
and that at that time i said i'll buy
one of these one day and rent it out to
people
i've got a network of people friends and
families and and i thought well if i've
got one i'm not going to use it all the
time i might as well rent it out for
everybody to enjoy so it's my little fun
business and that works i only spend a
couple of days on it i only do weekly
rentals so it's uh it comes in
clean it up out how much you're buying
for that
i paid 60 grand for it okay but it's
very nice brand new it's got two beds in
it
so first
and you're renting out for how much a
week a thousand pound plus v80 for a
week okay a thousand pound deposit is
required you've got to be over
oh 25 or 30 i think it is just got to
check them probably 25 yeah i think it's
25 yeah you got to be over 25 uh to rent
it
but it's it's my fun business basically
that's great so you've done you've done
that literally for a bit of fun you
wanted to buy a motorhome for yourself
was that always an ambition yeah yeah it
was on the to-do list yeah so and i've
done it i've done it it's it's out there
it went out for its first rental uh just
yesterday congratulations
yes what's the difference between you as
an investor now and say five years ago
like like what's how have your
strategies changed up when you're buying
houses oh well running them numbers and
doing the due diligence is uh so
important
and and
just checking everything is is so
important um making sure your roi you
know i didn't even know about roi i was
like i wanted the roi business um until
i came uh learning about property with
you um yields we were going off yields
or it gives a six percent yield seven
percent all that's a good ten percent
yield that's okay but it's not a croi
return on your money yeah cash on cash
cash on cash cash money sat in the bank
isn't doing anything yeah you know it
needs to go round that's how the economy
works it needs to go around that's why
the banks aren't giving you much
interest yeah you might as well make
money with that money and uh you know i
invest myself now and and it's all about
that roi and the time and and security
as well and being safe in in doing your
investment it's true because you can buy
if you buy a house you don't really know
what you're doing it might be that you
buy it in the wrong area you get a bad
tenant it doesn't actually make any
money at all it could even lose money
which some accidental landlords or
amateur landlords face your property
that you're buying at the moment is not
only is it a really high cash flowing
hmo which is going to be cash flowing
what did you say 37 grand a year 37 000
a year that's incredible how much you
buying it for 105 000 and you've had
that's going through conveyancing at the
moment offer accepted ready to complete
yeah 105 grand whereabouts is it it's in
wigan okay yeah so what's the talk to me
about it so it's uh it's a
double-fronted
terrace property it's a three-bedroom at
the moment and we're going to convert
into a six stroke seven bed we're gonna
go for the six first and then next year
we're gonna apply for the planning
permission for the seventh we're gonna
it's gonna be a storeroom and then when
we get the planning permission we'll put
a bed in it it becomes a bedroom
brilliant brilliant because you need
plenty of permission anything over six
yeah you need planning permission for
but you're not gonna wait to get
planning you're gonna rent it out as a
six to begin with
and then down the line do seven exactly
okay so then i'm gonna spend about 120
000 on it that's a big amount it is a
big amount so buying it for 100 spending
120 on it yeah is it run down at the
moment yeah it's run down and we're
going to go back to break we're going to
do a six on suites
or seven ensuite so yeah all gonna
happen all your builders quotes come
through yeah builders and 120 grand
that's a sensible amount to
conservatively say to take a big
property knock it back to the brick put
it into you know ensuite rooms high end
i can see what's going to be cash
flowing 37 grand however as an academy
member i'd like to think that once you
finish the refurb you'll be able to
refinance and pull out most of your
money so you're buying it for 105.
you're spending 120 on it which means
total that's two to five yeah what's the
end value gonna be we're aiming about
um
330 340 something well that's
conservative and then you'll refinance
it
and you'll pull 75 of the new value out
which means you'll pull out all your
money correct which will be a free house
yes that's awesome that's the idea now
as you can imagine
i had to do so much research for go
through all the crap properties to get
to this one yeah and
you know the process of learning and
you know
so i i viewed so many properties when
you when you did the dfe yeah there was
a challenge he who books the uh
most bookings wins a thousand pounds do
you remember giving thousand pounds out
yeah well it was me that won it did you
get a grand yeah oh i don't know that no
you remember no i won the thousand
pounds i've got a picture of me on the
stage with that granddad
oh wow yeah yeah so i won that
i was i'm a phone man i work off my
phone and it was really easy for me to
call agents and book i booked 67
viewings um um in in the manchester area
to view terraced houses properties i
gave them a certain criteria agents were
brilliant with me yeah yeah i'll get you
booked in over a couple of weeks
i went and viewed him
as a student because at that time i was
a student i'm thinking right i've got to
get experience on these properties and
when you're going around properties and
you're weighing everything up you're
looking at the cracks and you're
physically doing these viewings and
you you gain knowledge you gain a lot of
knowledge it took a lot of my time yeah
and petrol and you know to go and do the
viewing
and to
just get that knowledge and and
understand properties understand agents
how everything works yeah i was changing
from takeaways taxis restaurants to to
property to becoming a property investor
now let's see so it was uh it was yeah
life-changing
i do remember at the deal for next
travel gowns because obviously as you
know we go through how to book a viewing
can we give you the viewing checklist
yeah and everything yeah but then now
you got to do it do it
right you got you can't just be
theoretical you got to go do it go and
do it so there's usually incentives and
stuff like that but um i think without
knowing what to look for in the
properties yeah you could be clueless
but when you've got that checklist
exactly the checklist and you're
actually physically i'm a doer go and do
it and find out go and view it and find
out yeah there's one house that looks
absolutely beautiful
i'm like well okay stage very nice and
then i opened this cupboard and there's
a massive crack yeah
in the wall and thought that can't be
good
yeah
yeah
um but you learn about this boiler roof
fuse box you need to know what to look
for and i think as well because you've
become really good at finding deals
you're buying houses yourself um but
people are now paying you
it's almost like you're getting paid to
view houses
yeah we are we're like the uh personal
shopper uh for busy professionals
basically yeah and that's my my job to
go out there view houses find a good
deal and let the investor take that deal
on yeah and that's what we do as a
business day in day out and we've built
relationships up rapport up with the
agents and we're getting deals coming to
us
it's like you know
when you're at the events you're like
no you're questioning everything will
this work will this work will this no
well when you know a few foot months
down line and like everything's actually
happening everything that uh
samuel said on the train and alistair
said on the training is actually coming
together yeah it's like light bulb
moments wow this [ __ ] really works yeah
it does yeah and that's why we're able
to have a winners on a wednesday every
week yeah exactly yeah i was like your
winners on a wednesday your sunday q a's
and all the all the events that you put
i was just thinking this guy's running a
thousand miles an hour when's he going
to sleep
you know you did a fantastic job putting
your company together thanks i
appreciate that and as as well like
throughout the academy
you know you're you're successful but
the thing is it's not just you it's like
everybody is winning oh the network the
people uh all you winners on a wednesday
i know them they know me
i've i've made friends for life in the
in the property uh world
and
i was a networking ninja um you know
people watching this will say oh yeah i
remember him i remember him um i loved
talking to people i was a taxi driver
you know i was i was talking to people
all the time i love talk i love people
i'm a people's man you see and
networking was my thing that's my thing
nick working in investors and building
teams they're my things you see
and uh yeah made lots of really good
friends and you know if i need any
advice we're all there to help each
other support each other build each
other up yeah a lot of hate out there in
the world and um you know people that
haven't been on training you know you
you see oh yeah your comment's not nice
but then there's people that actually do
support you and it's lovely watching my
facebook some people are positive some
people are negative and things like that
what's the best thing about the actual
training programs because you've
obviously gone on a lot of them
not just with my company but you've gone
on a lot of training
training programs prior to even even
meeting me on the business side of
things but what's the what's the reason
that you keep coming on these training
programs
like-minded people um you know people
that want to grow people that want to
make something of their life people that
want to do looking for a different
direction in life
and you meet quality people on these
training programs um and a lot of my new
friends are all from
these training programs networking to
support everybody it's not about money
it's about support give give help each
other and so on i was helped and i like
to give that back to people as well and
and support them people will ask me
questions and things like that and i'll
i'll i'll share my knowledge it's in a
whole environment isn't it it's like you
say it's like a property family yeah um
you've obviously been
connected with me for a long time like
the fact that you came to a training
kings event
which was a christian business network
you're muslim though right i'm muslim
but still we open every we open
everybody so uh for anyone that knows my
backstory we know that previously to
running a property training company i
was running a christian business uh
training organization to help people
that were of faith whether they'd be
muslim sikh christian whatever but
people that might battle with this idea
of wanting to be holy and right and good
and
and a good humble person but at the same
time wanting to be successful in
business how do you do the two together
that's kind of what was the purpose of
it which then became more about property
and everyone was asking for so we
registered the property trading company
so you went through training kings
i registered my training company my
property training company 2016 which is
when we first met yeah you've trained
with me at events before
i even had a property training company
you've then gone through my free courses
you spent three years thinking about it
you went through the academy and now
it's 2021 you're smashing it in in
property business so what's the vision
now then what's the plan you've you've
got this successful deal sourcing
company which you've systemized in part
you've got your own properties going on
your motorhome what's next yeah
for me i think um
grow the deal sourcing side of things
and build my own portfolio i think the
the target is to get to that million
fresh new properties not the old stuff
and but from scratch they've got the vrr
project going on from there i think can
build up to uh
a million pound portfolio yeah and and
then
after that i might 10x the whole thing
who knows
who knows i'll retire i don't think
you're going to do that somehow though i
think you're going to continue growing
and working and helping other people do
the same i think yeah you've hit the
nail on the head they're helping other
people obviously i got so much support
out there for when i did the training
and i'd love to give that back to people
as well yeah so i think yeah i'll be
doing something in the line of helping
other people and achieve their goals
yeah um you know i've achieved a certain
amount up to now and uh and if i can do
it i know i can train other people to
get to this stage where i'm at yeah
obviously and that's one of the reasons
why you came on to inspire other people
yeah other people can see what you've
done they can see what i've done
actually you know what i can do that
yeah i think so and you've got to
surround yourself with the right people
as well supportive people that will help
you
build and grow grow as a person and so
on i watch people
on your stage that you know when they're
on right at the beginning they were like
very weak and so on and then
about six months down the line they're
such confident characters and they've
got so much knowledge and they you know
just by putting them on your stage they
grew you know yeah and um yeah it's it's
an absolutely brilliant process you're
gonna put out that i was lacking in
action
you know taking action in things and i
thought right i was looking for a
company i thought perfect action invest
yeah so that's how the um word because i
was i was down at the time you know
liquidating my company
and uh i decided right action is what
i'm lacking action invest that's what
i'll call it yeah it helped me um what
would you say what's the strongest
reason that you're doing all of this
my daughter was born in 2018 and life
changed um when my daughter was born
i've got responsibilities now
and um you know i want to help as many
people you inspired me going to uganda
and helping people over there i've got
bangladesh bangladesh is my parental
land
and my uncle's got a little charity
going where he builds houses for 400
pounds someone can have a tin house and
this tin house is actually
like a palace for them
um and i think i'm going to get involved
in in helping a bit more in bangladesh
and you know i i want to do that yeah
yeah yeah that's great yeah definitely
and how's life changed for you over the
last couple of years since building up
your property business um well
i'm a lot more confident i'm back in
business
and i'm getting myself out there i did
your program tell the world program um
that that you know i've had facebook for
so long but i've never done a live
uh on facebook and that helped me get
myself out there and spread the good
word you know of what i'm doing keeping
people in the loop for what's going on
when i shut down my businesses i never
told anybody what was happening and
things like that and really doing this
this interview um
will let them know
you know what happened in my previous
business because i made a lot of friends
a lot of customers you know
that were my friends and things like
that and they just didn't know i just
like sort of disappeared overnight and
by doing this interview it will let them
the cat is out the back
tell the world what are you doing so
what would you say to somebody that was
thinking about coming on the property
investors crash course they were
thinking about starting on this world of
education and training programs but was
unsure maybe they were a little bit
skeptical or that
you know they think oh i don't want to
be around lots and lots of people it
might be a little bit uncomfortable and
they're thinking about it what would you
say yeah get yourself out there get
yourself there get yourself to the
course uh just do it uh you got nothing
to lose you know surround yourself with
quality people what what can go wrong
yeah who you're around is who you become
yes and there's business training
programs with great people waiting to
meet you yeah so um that's awesome final
words of advice to someone wanting to
get started maybe they've had a failed
business before the fact that they've
just made their business go into
liquidation or they're struggling
haven't got much money struggling with
security issues
but they want to be successful in
property final words of advice
um life's a roller coaster it's up and
down it's up and down hold on tight and
enjoy the ride
um you get there in the end if you've
got that burning desire and it'll all
just happen
things do go wrong that's life yeah
never give up yeah uh is what i'd say
and never give up
yeah never give up that's brilliant
well guys i hope you enjoyed that
interview with mel ella if you want to
check out his company and connect with
him i'm going to leave in the
description his details and his uh his
his still sourcing company check him out
on social media as well also don't
forget if you haven't yet subscribed to
the channel please do subscribe right
now smash the like button drop a comment
in in the in the comment box below and
if you'd like to join me at the property
investors crash course you'll probably
see more there too then please do
check out the link in the description
i'd love to see you there in person and
who knows maybe in 6 12 months you might
be in my house and i could be
interviewing you where you can share
your journey to financial freedom as
moda's done here today thanks so much
and we'll see you next time peace out